opinion polls consistently put Merkel's
party far ahead in the run-up to
Germany's parliamentary election but the
Chancellor predicts a closed outcome and
has appealed to her supporters please if
you want to be sure to avoid experiments
such as trying to make a socialist green
coalition work then please cast your
ballots for the Christian Democrats
women they're Kirsty MacArthur's new
annual miracle says only her government
can steer a stable course in Europe to
introduce real reform not just financial
aid to the EU s embattled economies she
warns a red-green coalition would demand
collective European debt the Chancellor
also rejects opposition tax plans as
disastrous for Germany's economy should
be allowed to grow and create jobs
they shouldn't be crippled by tax hikes
and ease of study
miracle did not mention an unpopular CDU
proposition to introduce tolls for
Germany's autobahns the issue has split
the Christian Democrats and their
Bavarian wing the CSU this was a well
orchestrated show of unity behind a
leader with a commanding lead in the
polls